[Music]
but the ethical essence has split itself
into two laws and consciousness as an
undivided attitude towards law is
assigned only to one just as this simple
unitary consciousness and since as it's
absolute right that the essence has
appeared to it quantico as the essence
is in itself so to this essence insists
on the right belonging to its reality or
in its own right to be a two-fold
essence but at the same time this right
of the essence does not stand over
against self-consciousness as if the
essence existed somewhere else on the
contrary it is self-consciousness is own
essence it has its existence and its
power in self-consciousness alone and
its antithesis is the act of
self-consciousness itself for this
latter just because it is a self to
itself and advances to action raises
itself out of this simple immediacy and
spontaneously splits itself into two by
this act it gives up the specific
quality of the ethical life of being the
simple certainty of immediate truth and
initiates the division of itself into
itself and the active principle and into
the reality over against it a reality
which for it is negative by the deed
therefore it becomes guilt for the deed
is its own doing and doing it is its
inmost nature and the guilt also
acquires the meaning of crime for a
simple ethical consciousness it has
turned again is turned towards one law
but turned its back on the other and
violates the latter by its deed guilt is
not an indifferent ambiguous affair as
if the deed is actually seen in the
light of day could or perhaps could not
be the action of the self as if with the
doing of it there could be linked
something external and accidental that
did not belong to it from which aspect
therefore the action would be innocent
on the contrary the action is itself is
splitting into two this explicit self
affirmation and the establishing over
against itself of an alien external
reality that there is such a reality
this stems from the action
and results from it innocence therefore
is merely not action like the mere being
of a stone not even that of a child as
regards content however the ethical
action contains the moment of crime
because it does not do away with the
natural allocation of the two laws to
the two sexes but rather being an
undivided attitude towards the law
remains within the sphere of natural
immediacy and quat action turns its
one-sidedness into guilt by seizing on
only one side of the essence and
adopting a negative attitude towards the
other that is violating it the place in
the universal ethical life of guilt and
crime of deeds and actions will find
more definite expression later but this
much is immediately evident that it is
not this particular individual who acts
and is guilty for as itself he is only
the unreal shadow or he exists merely as
a universal self an individuality is
purely the formal movement of the action
as such the content being the laws and
customs which for the individual are
those of his class and station he is the
substance qua genus which by its
determinate 'no speak um indeed a
species though the species remains at
the same time the universal the genus
self-consciousness within the nation
descends from the universal only as far
down as mere particularity and not down
to the single individuality which posits
an exclusive self and actual existence
which in its action is negative towards
itself on the contrary its action rests
on secure confidence in the whole
unmixed with any alien element neither
with fear nor hostility
here now in paragraph 468 we are arrived
at a critical point a real crux or
crossroads for the development of spirit
and self consciousness in this second
subsection of the first section of the
spirits portion of the work and why do I
say that about this very long paragraph
in which there's a lot of things
developing because Hegel was now
introducing two new and related concepts
not completely new because you did also
talk about crime to blacken earlier on
in the work in other places but but here
this is taking place within
self-consciousness and primarily as
guilt or should and why why is that
happening what is there to be guilty
about
and why is guilt felt in the first place
so there's a lot going on here and one
of the key things that I think I'd like
to highlight from the beginning before
going into any sort of explication of
the text is that self-consciousness
quiet achill consciousness with all
these interesting qualifications of it
as representing the one law here Hegel
presented as typically with the
dialectic sort of emerging or rejecting
or pushing its own other out of its very
own self so we have the logic here of
the self same repelling itself from
itself and being attracted in a certain
way to its other to its opposite to its
it's different and this is particularly
important for for this section because
what it suggests is that guilt is not
something that comes solely from outside
or simply from internalization
in a kind of irrational or arbitrary way
of something that one doesn't actually
identify with there in the very ethical
action itself guilt is their implicit
and crime after it so let's see how does
this plays itself out he tells us the
ethical essence of split itself into two
laws okay no no surprise there we've
been talking about this now for many
paragraphs and consciousness as an
undivided attitude towards law is
assigned only to one again that sort of
you know just rehearsing what we've
already passed through so many times and
then he says just as this simple unitary
consciousness insist as it's absolute
right that the essence the phase of the
what is essential what is important in
the ethical has appeared to it has we
might even say spoken to it given it a
law quiet achill as the essence is in
itself so to this essence the essence
that is speaking to it insist on the
right belonging to its reality or on its
own right to be a two-fold essence so
again not a lot of surprises up until
this point because we've seen that the
the essence of the ethical substance
will break itself into the human law and
the divine law we've gone through a lot
of dialectical exposition of what
exactly that means sometimes with a few
interesting digressions about death and
you know the nature of government and
all these sorts of things what's the
upshot of this so Hegel tells us now the
right of the essence does not stand over
against self-consciousness and this the
essence existed somewhere else so
self-consciousness is not there and then
hearing the call or having imposed on it
what the ethical substance is saying
including the choice pick one side or
the other no that is happening within
self-consciousness
self so it tells us it is self
consciousness is own essence it has its
existence and its power in self
consciousness alone the ethical cannot
be dealt with without taking into
account self consciousness so the notion
you know there's a little bit of a
digression here the notion that we could
somehow turn anything that genuinely is
ethical and in Hegel sense substantively
ethical we might say into something like
a decision procedure or an algorithm
something that might be programmed into
another being and then just sort of you
know spooled out from there
Hegel would say that's fundamentally
mistaken the ethical itself has the very
structure of self consciousness because
there is ethics and the ethical only for
self consciousness not mere
consciousness but self consciousness and
when that happens there's inevitably
going to be this splitting that is
taking place so he tells us it's
antithesis is the act of self
consciousness itself the setting the two
laws apart into each other even though
the self consciousness qua individual
self consciousness makes it sleep jumps
into one of these or perhaps is assigned
by sort of natural division as we've
seen with the gender or sex division
that he's talked about there is still
sort of a hint or a shadow or a residue
of the other side of the reality of the
other law hanging around there even
though it can't be formulated as such by
by that person because they might say
dazzled by the demands of the ethical as
they're conceiving of it so he says just
because it is the self to itself in
advance as to action raises itself on a
simple immediacy a simple immediacy that
he's later going to call innocence and
analyze very very briefly in terms of
something
almost like a childhood right when it
acts it advances to action it raises
itself out of this immediacy
spontaneously splits itself into two and
what are the implications of this what
is the upshot Hegel tells us by this act
it gives up the specific quality of the
ethical life of being the simple
certainty of immediate truth remember
that as we've been discussing it so far
one of the hallmarks of the ethical is
this immediacy is this conviction that
it whatever the person is doing they are
following what the law requires whether
it be the human law administered by the
government a law that is manifest and
open to all or whether it be the divine
law which governs the family and govern
it tells us about those relations and
what they owe to each other something
that is hidden from the outside but is
nevertheless just as real either one of
those taking either of those sides gave
a certain conviction to the person who
was wholeheartedly doing that we just
discussed that in the previous
paragraphs now Hegel is saying even with
that conviction there is still going to
be a splitting going on and that's going
to undo something like a naivete to it
or a pure sincerity to it so he goes on
and he tells us it gives up the specific
quantity of ethical life and initiates
the division of itself into itself as
the active principle that is self
consciousness and the reality over
against it a reality which for it is
negative this self consciousness is
identifying itself with one law treating
it as as I put here the one law the law
that or the norm that that decides
things that makes a difference
but there is still the other law which
is a reality which is being treated here
as purely negative and as we've seen in
the Hegelian system so this is coming
from the ethical consciousness as a kind
of you know it's call it projection
right out itself the negative is usually
in in Hegel's dialectic where freedom
lies where something new can arise and
what we're going to see this negativity
takes shape here in the difference
between the two laws and what the person
is able to do Hegel is going to talk
about this in terms of action or doing
or deed right so he tells us now
immediately after this by the deed it
therefore becomes guilt so by acting it
brings guilt upon itself again we need
to think about this not in terms of
bringing guilt upon itself by triggering
a tripwire of laws falling afoul of
those who are in power running into some
foreign source that it didn't know about
transgressing some religious norm no it
brings guilt into itself by its action
in the first place to act is to
introduce the possibility of guilt but
one way we might think about this
Aristotle had talked about that one of
the differences between the practical
and the theoretical in very very broad
terms is that the faculty that deal with
the practical are dealing with human
lives and actions where things can be
different than they are and can be right
or wrong and we don't even have laws
that tell us exactly in every single
case what is right or wrong the best we
have this host epitope Allu you know for
the most part now
whenever we act we always introduce
Hegel's saying not just the possibility
but something like an actuality of guilt
involved in that debt action so he says
the deed why does it become guilt
because the deed is its own doing and
doing is its in most nature why is that
an explanation well part of what it
means to do to act - you know this
Britain German hood right - to make
something happen - to do something - to
affect something part of that is to
change the universe and generally to
change it in a purpose of way right we
saw that this in the reason section you
know Zach messy good right purpose of
Hegel thinks that this is central to
activity well whenever we do something
with a purpose there's always more
involved there so let's see what that
more actually looks like he says here
guilt
also acquires the meaning of crime why
for a simple ethical consciousness it
has turned towards one law the law that
it identifies with but it turned its
back on the other by turning it back on
the other law and regarding it as a
foreign alien reality that is standing
in its way it's not treating it as a law
but it's still in some respects subject
to it as a law so Hegel goes on and says
it treats it as an indifferent thing
right and it violates the latter
violates the law over here by its very
deed you might say that the ethical
universe is kind of a cramped one where
you can't help bumping into other laws
other norms other ways of
doing things you can't encompass it all
within yourself as you might wish to or
pretend to and instead you end up
violating something else that does have
the essence of the ethical so he goes on
and he says this is you know guilt he
says is not an indifferent ambiguous
affair as if the deed has actually seen
in the light they could or perhaps could
not be the action of the self as if with
the doing of it there could not be
linked something there could be linked
something external and accidental that
did not belong to it from which aspect
therefore the action would be innocent
Hegel is saying no no those those are
ways in which we do talk about guilt but
that is not what guilt means here the
real core essence of guilt of should in
in the German is that the person by
doing something has taken on something
like a stain there is some sort of
wrongness involved some responsibility
that they cannot evade they cannot
escape from and cannot merely attribute
to something outside of themselves
whether it be the thing that tells them
that they're guilty or the thing that's
supposed to have made them guilty it
belongs to them and it is a vote by
their action so he goes on and says on
the contrary the action itself is
splitting into two explicit
self-affirmation I am going to take the
side of the ethical as I understand it
through this one law the law of the
family or the law of the nation that's
part of the action the other side is
what the other part that's been split
into two he goes on and says the
establishing over against itself an
alien external reality then he says that
there is such a reality this stems from
the action itself and results from it so
it's not as if there's simply this other
law and the acting person
has merely disregarded it but you know
if they'd been better informed they
could have done justice to it know by
the very fact of not just taking this
side but acting in favor of this side
they you might say bring to the fore the
claims of this other law which does
exist it's not as if it's merely a
projection of self consciousness it is
there for self consciousness to
encounter but it's force what it is that
allows this law to convict the person as
engaging in crime that that the force of
that is indeed coming from self
consciousness whether self consciousness
realizes it or not so Hegel goes on and
says innocence the opposite of guilt or
initialled
right in German innocence is merely non
action like the mere being of a stone
not even that of a child this is a very
interesting thing to say we usually
think of children as innocent don't we
we talk about them that way Oh
somebody stole the innocence of a child
this is so horrible that crime is worse
than any other Hegel does not say here
that even a child has innocence but
innocence is in a certain sense a lack a
lack of being able to present reality
and to modify or to stake out reality
through action through doing bringing on
oneself the guilt that is involved so he
says as regards content the ethical
action contains the moment of crime why
because it does not do away with this
natural allocation of the two laws to
the two sexes but rather being an
undivided attitude towards the law
remains within the sphere of natural
immediacy qua action turns us
one-sidedness into guilt by seizing on
only one side of the essence and
adopting a negative attitude towards
other that is violating it so what is it
doing here it adopts an attitude that
makes this negative and then treats it
as a negative
it negates it and what result is guilt a
sort of complex negativity there's a lot
going on here and this passage isn't
there once we start unpacking it so what
else can we derive from this we now have
guilt crime within the very ethical
action itself because one law is being
respected and one law is being violated
at the same time it seems like a tragic
situation Hegel goes on and he tells us
that the place in the universal ethical
life of guilt and crime deeds and
actions is going to find more definite
expression later he's saying I have just
introduced these concepts we are now
going to work with them and you'll see
this happening in the next two
paragraphs for for example and then
further on in here but he said this much
is immediately evident it is not this
particular individual who acts and is
guilty for as this self he is only the
unreal shadow we exist merely as a
universal self individuality is purely a
formal moment of the action as such so
what's what's important than if it's not
just the individual he goes on he tells
us the content is the laws and customs
which for the individual are those of
his class and station Hegel is talking
about people who exist within concrete
social context we might say those which
have been given to them by their society
and by the generations that they belong
to in their family so it's not just as
any old individual it's not just as in
individual as such it's rather as an
individual who is rooted within some
sort of community within some sort of
history that this dynamic can really
play itself out that's not to say that
this could not apply to say an exile
right but an exile was an exile in a new
place from an other community so there's
still that attachment there now Hegel
starts to get very metaphysical with us
he says he is the substance quad genus
which biased determinate nacinda species
right so substance quad genus higher
level of abstraction goes to become a
species species is a lower level of
abstraction traditionally the way that
the distinction between genus and
species had been made was that the
species is what unites individuals
together and the genus is what unites
species together in the same sort of
relation of course in dialectics it gets
a bit trickier than that because as
we're going to see right after this
Hegel says that the species is the
universal of the genus which is almost
the opposite of what we would expect
them right so he tells us
self-consciousness within the nation
descends from the universal only as far
down as mere particularity not down to
the single individuality which posits an
exclusive self an actual existence which
in its action is negative towards itself
so what is the difference there what
what is the distinction he's making
between particularity and single
individuality single individuality is it
has this Force of the negative not only
towards the world but also within itself
it is truly for itself Hegel says on the
contrary its action rests on secure
confidence in the whole unmixed with any
alien element neither fee
nor hostility we are dealing with
particulars available within a community
so that is where the conflict is going
to take place does that mean that we're
not actually talking about individuals
no of course we're talking about
individuals but it's how those
individuals conceive of themselves their
action their guilt and their relation
with the ethical with the law that they
identify with and the law that they
identify against
you